making movies is dangerous business and
make an exciting movies can be downright
deadly it's not all special effects
there's real danger that goes along with
all that big screen magic here's a look
at a few famous movie scenes that nearly
killed actors Daniel day-lewis
despite Daniel day-lewis his habit of
putting himself in danger for his roles
no stunts were as dangerous as the
pneumonia the actor contracted on the
set of gangs of New York after refusing
to wear anything other than his ragged
19th century wardrobe coat
despite frigid temperatures he also
apparently fought random strangers while
filming in Rome just to keep in
character as the violent build the
butcher we describe to the independent
as a bit of a punk a marvelous character
and a joy to be but not so good for my
physical or mental health a quote
unquote joy to be is an interesting way
to describe getting your butt kicked by
Italian randos but then again we're
talking about a guy who spent three
years getting punched in the head to
prepare for the boxer by former champ
Barry McGuigan so maybe everything he
says isn't going to make the most sense
I drink your milkshake Jennifer Lawrence
accident-prone Jennifer Lawrence has a
habit of taking public spills but it was
no laughing matter with a smoke machine
malfunction and almost suffocated her on
the set of The Hunger Games Mockingjay
part 1 according to an insider on the
set filming came to an abrupt halt when
this fog machine broke and began spewing
so much dense smoke during a tunnel
sequence that Jennifer literally
disappeared from sight luckily she
escaped with only a bit of vertigo and
nausea but this wasn't the only time The
Hunger Games series knocked her around
during training she ran into a wall
sparking rumors that she had damaged her
spleen oh sorry
spleen juice which turned out to be
false but the next time everyone freaks
out when Lawrence asked to be paid the
same as her male co-stars maybe we
should all remember that she's willing
to bleed for our entertainment Joseph
gordon-levitt
after safely starring in a Batman movie
a time-traveling assassin movie and a GI
Joe movie Joseph gordon-levitt was
almost killed while playing a bike
messenger while 30 miles per hour might
not sound too fast
cruising between moving cars at that
speed on a bike is pretty serious a taxi
drove over safety cones during filming
of premium rush and cut gordon-levitt
off sending him through the rear
windshield and badly
icing up his forearm joke out the award
for most stitches with 31 when he went
through the back window of a cab it's
funny how much attention you'll get when
there's some blood loss this is Joe's
bike and that's where he ended up
director David Koepp feared he was dead
later told MTV and you're you know for
about 15 seconds before I could get
there and see what happened I'm thinking
did I kill him that I took that I
actually kill an actor
Gordon Levitt actually laughed the whole
thing off but we wonder if he thought it
was so funny when the movie's worldwide
gross came in four million dollars below
the production budget Jackie Chan the
list of Jackie Chan's endless onset
injuries is basically a medical
encyclopedia busted up body parts but
his injury on the set of armor of God
too was the worst of all compared to
some of the stuff he's done like sliding
down the side of a skyscraper and
getting hit by a real flying helicopter
the armor of God two stunts was tame all
he had to do was jump into a tree but he
missed and fell to the ground smacking
his head on a rock which send a piece of
his skull into his brain the injury
required brain surgery and a metal plate
implanted enchance skull amazingly this
happened in the early 90s and Chan
continued to make many more films
performing almost all of his own stunts
in other words the exact opposite of
what any normal person would do but then
Jackie Chan is an ax normal person I
wouldn't be a friend kiss service ah
difficult donald sutherland most of the
people on this list were badly injured
and yes could have been killed in their
onset accidents but no one through quite
the nightmare donald sutherland endured
because he actually died on the set of
Kelly's heroes in 1968 sutherland
contracted bacterial meningitis from a
danube river and had an out-of-body
experience his description of the
incident is truly chilling the downward
journey slowed and stopped I'd been on
my way to being dead when some memory of
the desperate rigor I'd applied to
survive all my childhood illnesses
pulled me back forced me to live I was
alive I'd come out of the coma sick as a
dog but alive both poetic and terrifying
all at once Sutherland took over six
weeks to recover at which point is
contract for stand back on screen with
his brain still fried afraid of water
and Heights and according to him
constantly weeping
don't hit me with him negative waves so
early in the morning jason statham
action star jason statham knew exactly
what to expect when sylvester stallone
asked him back to the Expendables 3
except for the fact that he'd almost get
drowned blown up or crushed to death
whichever one of those happens when you
accidentally drive a truck off a loading
dock something went wrong with the
brakes in Stevens vehicle causing the
truck to quickly plunge 60 feet but
Statham who once competed as an Olympic
diver was able to get free the survival
sort of kicks in and you pull yourself
out the window you stop grabbing at the
wall and trying to get to the surfing
anything was a dad I mean they don't
call it the Black Sea for no reason
apparently sly was unconcerned look out
I said where's sly and he's you know
stood on the side of the dock now with
his iPhone without that good Jason you
knew the dull thanks for watching
but the looper icons subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]
you